tu as they say en dessin c'est quand tu
voles il est super beau ton dessin titi
c'est exactement comme ça mais léo
pourquoi je peux pas pu voir un vrai
quand idole et personne qui peut vous
voir c'est pour ça que c'est un secret
j'ai envoyé un virus informatique
particulièrement redoutable avec un
milliard de dollars
au cous et tout arrêter
les new york ici on va pas se laisser
impressionner par 1,5 de plus marie
c'est peut-être dangereux j'ai devant
moi un vrai policier de new york la
classe moi je peux vous aider vous allez
voir bon je résume tu t'assois tu fermes
les yeux et tu bouges plus il est
vraiment super ton plan ça y est la voix
mais tu sais ce qu'elle fait matin
mais aussi ce que tu dis est vrai il
faut qu'elle se retire de là tout de
suite
non tout cas longtemps un flic à
roulettes
il faut une future sacré long d'un chien
ok avec la gueule d'un requin dépêche
toi allez hop on a besoin de ton fantôme
la ferme c'est pas le moment de paniquer
vous préviens d'un ami j'ai manqué de
patience
oui
je m'appelle neo geo zan et j'ai un
secret je suis un héros